the will
is the mental faculty that gives you the
ability to hold one idea on the screen
of the mind to the exclusion of all
outside distractions or
ideas i want you to start dreaming about
what you want and then discipline
yourself that you're going to execute it
now
you and i are constantly being inundated
with ideas through our senses
see hear smell taste touch it's flying
into our mind
it's so easy to get off track
[Music]
most information that you pick up just
as you go through your day is negative
it's very negative
most people spend most of their time
thinking of why things won't work
97 of the population are locked into
that
if you turn on your radio
or your tv the news it's all negative
it's not good news it's bad news
[Music]
and people will sit and stare at it
[Music]
now your mind works in such a way
[Music]
that if you're not thinking your
subconscious mind is wide open to
impression
and whatever's going on around goes
right into your subconscious mind you
become totally deductive to whatever the
environment you're in it's very
important that you mix with the right
people
i am super selective about people that i
spend a lot of time with i don't think
i'm any better than anybody i think i'm
a lot more fortunate than most but i
don't think i'm any better than anybody
there's just some people i don't want to
be around them a lot
[Music]
they're it's doom and gloom it's bad
times
[Music]
i love what earl nigel said don't talk
about your health unless you're talking
to a doctor you know if you're not
feeling well and you talk to somebody
about it you know what they're going to
do they're going to sympathize what are
they going to do they're going to add
more bad energy to the bad energy you're
talking and thinking about
[Music]
if you go to the doctor the doctor isn't
going to give you sympathy the doctor is
going to give you a direction now to get
better
so don't talk about your health unless
you're talking to a doctor you might
want to turn that into a little mantra
in your mind
well here we want to learn to make
decisions and then we want to discipline
ourselves
decision without discipline
probably turns into wishing
discipline is to give yourself a command
and then follow it it's the ability to
give yourself a command and then follow
this i will do as vaclav haval said
work for something because it is good
not just because it stands a chance to
succeed
this is something that i think a lot of
people misunderstand they think that the
goal of their life is to identify
something that'll work to identify
something that has the odds stacked in
its favor
rather than to think about
what matters
what's important
because if something is important if it
speaks to you if it's going to
give resonance to your life then it's
worth doing even if it's something that
is almost guaranteed to fail when
something matters enough regardless of
the odds it's worth engaging with
because even in the pursuit
you can find meaning and as humans one
of the things that we hunger for most is
purpose and meaning but you can't have
that purpose and meaning without the
thing that you're pursuing be something
that you believe to be worthwhile so
don't worry about whether or not it
succeeds ask only about whether or not
it's going to light you on fire ask only
if in those dark moments that it will
give you that sense of mattering to this
world that even in the failure do you
learn something about yourself do you
see
the truth
that you matter
and that even as a single person even as
one individual you can
echo through this world
but that will never happen by pursuing
something small
that will never happen by pursuing
something simply because it can win
it will only happen by pursuing
something that matters
and in that if you pursue something that
matters and you're able to get to the
point where you can see it across the
finish line or at least advance it and
make it a step closer to becoming real
in that we realize how societies really
are transformed in that and trying the
big the impossible dreaming that thing
that nobody else is even willing to talk
about in dreaming that it is the crazy
ones who are able to change the world
because the crazy ones allowed
themselves to believe
they allowed themselves to believe that
against all the odds a world that does
not yet exist could actually exist
and as ralph marsden said welcome those
big sticky complicated problems in them
are your most powerful opportunities and
that's it the big problems the ones that
matter the things that will give you
purpose and meaning in your life they're
going to be hard but if you can look at
the hard things and show up and push
every day and keep striving and when you
fall down pick yourself back up and
focus only on one thing not
whether or not you're going to win but
whether or not it mattered that you
played
if you do that
every sacrifice in your life will be
worth it
and if not
nothing you gain
will have mattered people think they
have to know how i called the tyranny of
how
like you get all excited i'm gonna do
this and then your brain goes i've never
done it before oh my god what do they
say i don't know how to do this
and they tend to focus on how to do it
and when you start with how you're
screwed
like
martin luther king had no idea how when
he did his i have a dream speech in fact
his wife was the one that pushed him
because he was uncertain right you know
the real history it's pretty interesting
but the bottom line is he gets up there
and he gives his vision of how it can be
done he talked about what needs to
happen and why
if you can figure out what you want and
why you want it and you get strong
enough reasons reasons that will drive
you late at night it'll get you up early
in the morning and the reasons are
different some people do it for
nitty-gritty reasons jim rohn used to
say because you know some guy told him
he borrowed money from this finance
company i forget the name of hfc finance
where the hell it was
and
you know he hadn't been back since he
borrowed the money you know so they're
calling them in those days they could
harass you in ways they can't today
right they would call him show up and
embarrass him in front of his neighbors
and so jim rohn this first real chunk of
money he told me he made because it's
like he set this goal it was his nitty
gritty reason his reason to get rich was
we could go down and pay this thing off
and he said he went to the bank and got
it all in cash and in small bills
and he bolted into this little hfc you
know finance place and the guy who
borrowed the money was the fourth best
back and he said i walked up there i
opened i opened up this brief and i
dumped all the money all over his desk
and small bills i said count it it's all
there i will never be back he said he
was startled because i hadn't been there
since i borrowed the money right but but
he did it for the degree but some people
do it for their kid
some people will do it like we almost
all do it for something more than
ourselves
some people do it because they like
winning
right i know that about you
right it's like i like winning i like
being the best at what i do so i'm not
going to settle for less than that why
would i
right so you got to find your reasons
but if you know what you want and you
get a big enough why now you'll figure
out how to do it but if you start with
how
you know the small brain the fear brain
goes so [ __ ] i don't know what they
don't know where to go i don't know what
to do 90 of time either i know what and
why and then i try some it doesn't work
i try something else or just something
else now i speed it up
by learning from the best so that's why
you know money mastery games is a
perfect example
my companies you know at the time were
100 million companies i had one 500
million company
now we're doing seven billion
i took what i learned from these guys i
applied it not only am i investing i
applied it to my own businesses why do i
reinvent the wheel when i just learn
from the best on earth i mean somebody's
that good can tell you that little two
millimeter thing that changes everything
so my life is really about learn from
the best but i don't start with the how
i start with the what and the why and i
think that's the mistake most people
make i want to show you what it looks
like when you learn something new you
have a hundred billion neurons in your
brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections
if you took
a hundred thousand hundred billion
sheets of paper and you stack them on
top of each other it would be five
thousand miles high that's the distance
from los angeles to london
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections
now
i'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections
every time you learn something new this
is what's happening in your brain
geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom
that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place
and learning is making new connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint
if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts
over and over again you're going to wire
them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves
into networks or what's called neural
networks
and neural networks are just gangs of
neurons
that have fired and wired together to
form a community of neurosynaptic
connections that's related to a thought
a skill a habit a behavior a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic you have to
learn to role model
positivity
and good values
right it's super hard to tack me online
at this point because for a decade and
over 300 episodes of a podcast and over
200 episodes of my youtube videos and
you know six best-selling books and and
literally being on stage in front of
millions of people and graduating
millions of people from our online
courses
the just the effort of all that the
messaging is so clear right i'm the guy
that tells you to be more intentional
i'm the guy that tells you to be a role
model i'm the guy that tells you be
excellent at what you do so you can be
of greater service to the world and the
more i talk about living fully and
loving opening and making more of a
difference of stepping into that role
model mindset of honoring the struggles
of life
in being authentically you
me the message ends up standing for
itself
you know they could attack you in a
video or they might like my shirt in
this video i think it's stupid i took a
picture of you know the cat or you know
they don't they judge me or my clothes
or my wife or something they see
but the totality of what you have done
no one gets to take away from that they
just don't even if they attack it
because here's what happens remember as
you build that big tribe you've imbued
good values in the marketplace
your tribe starts fighting for you your
tribe starts canceling the haters your
tribe starts fighting back for you
explaining for you your tribe starts
getting your back cause they're like
wait why are you judging this guy he's
put out a decade of free content
why are you judging this person they've
done all of these good works
and your community your tribe ends up
getting your back
when you have imbued that tribe with
good values and honestly demonstrated
but also commanded demanded bagged
pleaded cajoled for people to be
positive forces in the world you know at
base of all of my messaging has always
been that did i matter message
that message about servant leadership
that message about get so good at what
you do so you can be of greater service
to the world like how do the haters come
at me when my message is about
contribution
that's what you want to think about is
that as you role model positivity
contribution good values in the world
your tribe stands up for you but you
also stand up for yourself more because
you know true down deep in your heart
you're doing good work like no one can
make me question
my work i'm going to do this i tell my
team all the time i'm going to do this
i'm 100 years old
i'm always going to be that guy putting
out personal development and psychology
work i love that field it's what i care
deeply about and it's what i've stood
for for a decade and no one gets to take
that away from me
no one gets to take it away from you so
please don't let a hater ever slow you
down i hope that supports you and i hope
you always believe in your message you
have a voice you have great art and
contributions to give the world do not
slow down
make it raw not perfect this was a
really important lesson for me
early on i spent six months working on
an album it was four tracks six months i
worked on four tracks i polished and
polished and polished and perfected and
just did so much work on this record i
must have spent thousands and thousands
of hours working on this record this is
like over a decade ago
and like nothing happened from that
nobody cared about it like nobody cared
i remember it getting literally like
three plays a day on myspace then
pomp moose uploaded a video in 24 hours
once lady gaga came out with a song
called telephone and natalie and i
decided okay let's cover telephones
[Music]
and it was
not perfect it was raw and it was
just whatever we could do in 24 hours
that video now has 10 million views
and i i keep learning that lesson over
and over again and i contrast that
experience with like polishing this
record for six months
[Music]
it's still hard for me to come to terms
with that the polish doesn't necessarily
make it better and in fact a lot of
times polish makes things
worse there's an element of that about
like rock and roll
there's something about rock and roll
and the rawness of it and the realness
of it hearing somebody's voice crack and
hearing somebody scream and hearing
somebody be human
that just really attracts other human
beings scary pockets the other day um
did we recorded a track we do live takes
like six people in a room pre-pandemic
recording funk music together if you
flub a note it's in the recording and in
the middle the singer forgot the lyrics
[Music]
and instead of cutting we just kept
going
and we liked the take so we put it out
we put out the take and the singer
laughs and guess what all the youtube
comments were oh my god that laugh was
the most incredible things it's so great
to see real people making real music
together all the comments were about
this one moment of rawness this one
moment of vulnerability the process of
change usually starts with
self-awareness
now you can change without being aware
of it but you're not usually in control
it means that the environment shifted or
the circumstance or situation changed
and you changed in response but you
weren't really influencing it in a
meaningful way
so it starts with self-awareness then
the next step which you already
mentioned is kind of we could call it
different things called deliberate
practice call it routine or you know
whatever but you're consciously doing
the behavior so you're putting an effort
to practice it is there just to stop you
there is there any tricks
you know that you have found as far as
that part of it you know because people
don't get started they have too high of
goals i've heard a ton of different ones
but sure could you share with us you
know some tips on that part of it so i
think there are a couple maybe two let's
pick two strategies that you could use
right away so the first one is a lot of
people feel like they lack motivation
when what they really lack is clarity
and what i mean by that is they think i
need more willpower i need more
motivation i need more persistence i
need more drive
and certainly those are all important
qualities in life but the truth is they
we often make statements about how we
want to change in very vague ways we say
something like this time it'll be
different i'll just eat better i'm going
to try harder whatever
and instead if we have clarity and you
could use there are two strategies in
the book that i talk about for this one
is implementation intentions so
it is a intention to implement a
particular behavior so the simplest way
to do this is you fill out a sentence
that says exactly when and where the
behavior will occur so i will go to the
gym on monday at 5 pm at this address or
i will journal at this coffee shop at
you know 6 a.m blah blah and the more
clear that plan is the more likely they
are to follow through and there's a
bunch of research studies that show that
people are more likely to get their flu
shot quit smoking recycle exercise
basically any kind of habit you can
think of
to change your life
you have to be willing to change your
actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life
great don't change anything or you love
pieces of your life don't change
anything about those pieces but if you
are not happy with where you are at you
must be able be willing to do different
things otherwise you will stay stuck
forever i was doing an instagram live
yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing
self-doubt and fear and insecurity and
nobody's watching the stories and he's
not good enough and who am i to share a
message
in in her ig live one of the things he
said was
well i'm not i'm not comfortable
doing that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not
and he doesn't feel comfortable get in
front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say
i'm not comfortable doing that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying i'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values i get it
right you're not comfortable you know
i'm at costco right now nina's going
shopping in there i'm not comfortable
robbing costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day that's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it it's just you but you don't want to
fail in front of other people and that
can no longer be a good enough reason
because if you only do think about this
if you only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable you
stay in your comfort zone
and therefore
you hate your life
because if all you do is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're going
to hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs as you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you could you can see it you
can touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like i want to be there i
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more
but you're afraid to go off and do it
and and you fall back down to comfort at
least consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish
your great goals because everything you
want out of life is on the other side of
your comfort zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your big dreams your
big ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so i had to stop him when he was
talking to me on the instagram live
because it doesn't matter
if you're not comfortable doing it
it's actually the opposite because you
are uncomfortable doing it now you have
to do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop
is the big problem i don't care what
else you're gonna what other story
you're gonna tell me afterwards i had to
stop the conversation at that moment
because i could not allow him to
continue
with the mindset of i'm uncomfortable so
i'm going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and and you need
to catch them and you need to root them
out and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is the thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so i told him anytime you hear yourself
say
this makes me uncomfortable
again as long as it's not against your
value system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings any time somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you gotta go do that thing
as long as it's not against your value
system
right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
i would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me
not to go off and do the thing that i
want to do
i want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay i can't do it
i've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if i never do things that are
scary i will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
[Music]
you know when i when i was thinking
about doing my tour
in 2019 we had 23 cities 90 days
i thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like i'm i was
afraid to get on stage
and here i am now facing my fear every
four days in a new city i've never done
a tour and instead of just doing a small
tour of three cities or something like
23 cities 90 days you know a quarter of
the year on the road straight
with with my wife and my cameraman
okay let's go
because i do difficult things because i
want to train myself that i do difficult
things because again my dream life is on
the other side of me doing difficult
things if i only do what's easy
i'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little ribbon or
an award right you
you run a race against three-year-olds
and you win congratulations amazing you
won and you could post about on
instagram and you had this little moment
of accolade but you don't actually feel
good about yourself because you didn't
do anything difficult because that was
easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things
the willingness to show up even if you
don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today look the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before it's why most people do not
like their life it's why most people
drive to a job that they hate
they're driving to a job that hey most
people wake up all you know look at all
these cars here most people here in this
parking lot they're waking up every day
and driving to a job that they hate they
do not like their life most of the
people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so i call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing
now try to get to the reason behind the
reason
so example
somebody wants to make youtube videos i
want to i want to be a thought leader i
have a message in my heart i want to get
it out to the world awesome
what's the reason why you're telling
yourself you can't do it like oh well
i don't the time i don't have the camera
i don't have the gear no the microphone
i don't know what to say
uh all of these these are the practical
reasons right those are not the real
reasons the real reason is buried
underneath the practical reasons
why do you think that having
the right camera and microphone is going
to be the difference well because you're
actually afraid of judgment you're
afraid that people are going to watch it
we're afraid of when people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone
bad camera bad microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid to judge them
underneath the reason of
i don't have a good enough camera
microphone etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what you've been
delaying on what are you procrastinating
on what's the reason you're telling
yourself
the logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
failure if it's fear of not being good
enough if the fear of being imposter if
it's fear of being uncomfortable
whatever your actual fear is that's your
trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life and everything
and all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say i am the
person who does difficult things i am
the person who gets uncomfortable i am
the person who is going to change my
actions because that's the only way i'm
going to get the life that i want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and i've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted
comfort for example as a reason why you
can't take action and then you hear
yourself say
well that makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it
you take the brain out of the equation
now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now i have to
go and do it period
most people half of what they thought
today is the same things they thought
yesterday about themselves about their
life about the business that's why most
people's lives don't change very much
but if you wake up
and you start realizing i'm living in a
home an emotional home i don't want you
can change it
see because everybody's got if you've
got a billion dollars check this out if
you had a billion dollars
but the habitual emotions you go back to
are frustrated and pissed off
then your life is called frustrated and
pissed off it doesn't matter how much
money you have
write this down please the quality of my
life is the quality of my habitual
emotions
the quality of my entire life
is nothing but the quality of my
habitual emotions whatever habits of
emotion wherever my emotional home is i
will find a way to get back there and
until i change that i'm gonna have a
problem
how many of you see people in some part
of the world
in my country for example you'll see
this in the middle america where there's
certain places there have cyclones all
the time or maybe down in new orleans or
places where every few years you get a
huge storm that wipes out everybody
right on the coast there
but then two years later it happens
again they rebuild it happens again how
many have ever thought to yourself why
don't these people move
why don't they move guys
because it's what their condition they
call that home i don't want to leave my
home it's what i know
it's easy to see when it's somebody else
and it's physical it's harder to see
when it's yourself and it's emotional
because we have an emotional home some
of you grew up in a really tough
environment i did too pretty brutal
environment
very painful environment part of i am
who i am is because i didn't want to
suffer i had to find answers and because
i suffered so much i don't want you to
ever suffer if i can do anything about
it i can't control it but i can help
massively
but it's only because i suffered so much
don't want anybody else to
but think about it
most people suffer even when they're
successful
listen
if you're successful and you're not
fulfilled
that's the ultimate failure
if you've got people that love you and
you're not feeling joyous and alive
something's wrong and you know what it
is you got an old home you're used to
maybe the home you're used to is not a
very happy home it's a home of worry a
home of frustration home of anger a home
a feeling everything is unjust and so
you find a way to get back home using
whatever the environment you can use
[Music]
how many of you know somebody who's
always pissed off about something
how many of you know somebody
who is always worried
how many of you know someone
who is not really funny
as they think they are
and they crack himself up telling stupid
joe how many know something like this
who cracks themselves up and they laugh
so much that even though it's not funny
you find yourself laughing too
these people have different emotional
homes some people's home is anger
they'll always find something to be
angry about
it's what they're used to
it's their conditioning so even when the
storm comes in and messes up their life
they go right back to that safe
wouldn't it be nice to upgrade your home
your emotional home where you live
what if you could live every day with a
vast majority of the emotions you had
were
joy
and gratitude and love and appreciation
even in the middle of covet even when
somebody does something unjust
compassion
playfulness
what would that feel like if you were in
those states every day
90 95 percent of the time when you
weren't you got out of it quick
you can make that change this weekend
and i'm not exaggerating announced i'm
not saying you're going to be perfect
and never have a negative feeling
because negative feelings are sometimes
a signal to make us change but most
people are negative ceiling and they
just hang on to it and keep living with
it find other things to be negative
about
that will never give you what you want
the money won't do it
the acknowledgement of others won't do
it everything you think will do it will
not do only one thing will do it you
drawing a line the santa making the most
important decision of your life that
you're going to live in a beautiful
state no matter what because life is too
short
to suffer
we have a choice listen to me
pain is sometimes part of life but
suffering is a choice
but for most of us not a choice because
we have the habit of suffering being
stressed being worried being
frustrated being pissed off
and because we're wired that way
that's the muscle we built
but if we rebuild our home here so it's
even more magnificent then you can have
the life that you desire and deserve and
you do one weekend only if you give your
all and push enough energy out while
you're doing it while you're learning
let's start by looking backwards in
2021.
now this is going to seem like wow
thanks for bringing me here to depress
me today dean but i would love for you
and write this down i would love for you
to write down and think through what are
the regrets
failures
missed opportunities
botches mistakes whatever you want to
call it what are the regrets failures
mistakes or missed opportunities that
happened in 2021
i really want you to think about that
what went wrong
where did you procrastinate
where did you waste time
where did you miss an opportunity
what did you try and didn't work
really take a moment and write this down
this is part of setting up 2022 for the
win you can't know where you're gonna go
until you figure out where you've been
as we write these down and and i and i
see so many of you writing and i see
some of you not we all screwed up and
may did things wrong congratulations for
being human
congratulations for being human
if you listen
if you're on a quest to be a better
version of you i promise mistakes are
going to be made along the way
if you don't want to wear someone else's
name on the back of your jersey if you
want to live life to the fullest if you
don't want to see a video at the end of
your life of the woman that you could
have been then we are going to make
mistakes we are going to fail that means
that you are moving forward if you don't
have any mistakes in 2021 then i'm sorry
you didn't try enough you're playing it
safe and nothing is going to change i
want you to be disturbed with inaction
you want another level of life we got to
screw up we got to get out and step off
the path we got to get out of the norm
we got to get away from what's
comfortable you want to you want to take
the island you have to burn the boats
and in that journey you are going to
mess up you are going to fail you are
going to do things wrong
sarah blakely the the founder of spanx
who just sold for billions of dollars i
remember one of her stories about her
dad used to ask her all the time what
did you fail at today and if she said
nothing he's like well you didn't push
yourself
think about that philosophy
right what went wrong
what didn't work
because that is the building block to
who we're supposed to be
and this year i'm going to encourage you
to fail more
fail faster
fail bigger
be disturbed in a bigger way because
here's what i know if you fail up
something bigger you learn
bigger
lessons it's like if if you say ah
nothing really went wrong in 2021. then
you're talking out of both sides of your
mouth you're here because you want more
but you really didn't put the effort in
in 2021 you played it safe how is
playing it safe working out for you you
want to tell your maker at the end of
your life i played it safe how's that
going to feel you're going to want to
redo you're going to want to do it over
the things that you wrote down that
failed didn't work you procrastinated
what's one thing you learned from each
one of the things that you said you
failed what's one thing you learned i
tried marketing this way it didn't work
i tried this with my relationship it
didn't work i tried that diet it didn't
work
but what did work out of it you might
have figured out what doesn't work for
you i need to exercise in a variety
trying to do the same thing over and
over doesn't work me i tried counting
calories one time to get in like ideal
shape i can't do it i'm not the person
that's gonna figure out i need a diet
where i can just look at stuff and order
it or i don't mean a diet like i'm
dieting i just have a regular way of
eating exercise i need to mix up my
cardio i can't just run on a treadmill
every day if i try to do i get so bored
i quit but if i go run the mountain take
a job do the stairmaster do the uh do i
have the peloton it's amazing by the way
do the peloton bike go play racquetball
go play squash or pickleball if i mix
that up i'll do cardio five days a week
if i try to just sit on a treadmill
every day it doesn't work for me so i
know that can't work i also know in my
relationship
that if i don't if i work so much that i
don't look my wife in the eye every day
and ask her about our day and catch up
and have that time with my wife and i my
wife goes to bed a little bit sad
and i realize that that doesn't work for
me i don't care that my business is big
and i have hundreds of employees and i
i've got a million things going on
my wife the love of my life if i go home
and just kind of dismiss her day because
my stuff was bigger
then that woman doesn't look at me at
the way that i love the way she looks at
me so that was a little bit of a fail
because we went down the road and i was
starting to go down that road i got so
busy i was running tony's company
running my company writing a new book
flying all over and i'm like baby i love
you got some big stuff going on thank
you and i'd go to bed and i watched my
wife go to set go to bed sad for about
two months
and i didn't know why i'm like damn
what's going on because it was all about
me
i realized where i fail all i got to do
i'm so lucky it's so easy to be married
to my wife i just got to stop and go i
had a busy day babe but i missed you
what's up with you
and if we have 15 minutes of that talk
man
i got a
i got a
amazing wife that looks at me like
it's just the greatest thing on earth it
was a fail
until i figured out what went wrong and
what i learned from it and i shifted so
i want you to think about this i want
you to take two minutes right now and i
just want you to write down yeah you
failed but what could you have learned
from it marketing that way doesn't work
talking to my husband that way doesn't
work this kind of exercise doesn't
work but what did i learn i should mix
it up i should talk different i should
listen more i should market different i
need to get more capabilities i got to
dig back into the course those that you
got accelerated success formula got to
get back in the course project next got
to get back in the course got to get a
coach i don't know what it is but you'll
learn something from it i want you to
take those lessons now you can go back
you got your notes you know what we're
talking about you can go deeper on this
i want you to take those lessons
you have to take the things that went
wrong
identify them we have to jot down what
we can learn from them you ready for
this we want to take the things we
learned and i want you to have like this
hypothetical line drawn in the sand 2021
lives on this side 2022 lives on this
side
you take the things you learn from the
failures and you bring them over the
line
and you leave all the other crap in
2021.
picture it this way someone's i read
this once someplace and it stuck with me
and i'm going to paraphrase it now but
think about you have a house and it's
all shelves a building with all shelves
and it's all the things from 2021
and you're taking what serves you
you're taking the lessons learned and
you're putting them in a suitcase and
you're carrying them and then the place
catches on fire you let all the crap
that didn't work burned down in 2021 you
just carry out of the house or across
the finish line the things you learned
does that make sense because so many of
you are carrying regrets you're carrying
things that went wrong yes some of you
screwed up on relationships welcome to
being human some of you screwed up in
your business welcome to being human
some of you didn't eat right you didn't
take care of your health you know you
had diabetes you still ate like
okay you did it you want to regret and
carry that forever or you want to leave
it in the past so you can become the man
or the woman you were destined to be we
can't carry all the [ __ ] from our past
and try to become who we're meant to be
we got to find a line in the sand dennis
you're feeling me on this one and we got
to leave it in yesterday
that's how you identify
where you are
and where you need to bring it with you
the key to success
is look at successful people
and do what they do
and look at people who are just living a
mediocre life and don't do what they do
okay
really because that's what i did
i watched
and i studied people who were successful
i was born in liberty city
and over town i was raised living city
in overtown
and
i had friends
who lived on miami beach that i met
and i stayed around them i met them
while going to work with my mother who
was doing domestic work cleaning homes
on miami beach
and i heard one of the the families that
she worked for
mr sudersky say to his son you want to
be successful he said watch successful
people and do what they do and you
accomplish the things that i have
accomplished
and
watch poor people
and don't do what they do
that was some good advice he gave his
son i overheard the conversation i took
it to heart
i remember reading something about
jackie onassis
somebody asked her if you lost all of
your money
how would you get your wealth back
and i love her answer
she said i would go to the the most
expensive restaurant
and and move my table as close as i
possibly could
to people that are in there having
conversations
primarily wealthy people
order a glass of water
and ease drop
on their conversations
and in two years
i will get all my wealth back
whoa
that's something to think about
see the reason that
a lot of people are panicked right now
and and feeling anxious be anxious for
nothing
they're listening to the wrong people
right now
you want to be selective of who you
listen to
right now
you want to get around the right people
that lift your spirit that inspire you
that make you feel good that make you
laugh
and and remind you
that you have greatness in you
that you can overcome this
that let you know
that that you were made for this
see
when you think about life
people say it
it's challenging yes it is challenging
life is for our growth and development
you you cannot develop growth without
being challenged
faith
not tested can't be trusted in life you
will always
be tested
stuff's going to happen to you you're
gonna lose people you're gonna get sick
tragedies accidents all kinds of stuff
will be thrown at you
but it doesn't matter about those things
what matter most is about you
how you handle it
and see most people are pessimistic they
look at a difficult situation
and
they they they give up and they
surrender they become negative
pessimistic people
they can look at opportunities
and they'll say nah
it won't work
why because they're pessimistic
an optimist will look at difficult
situations
and they'll look at
obstacles
and optimists will say you know what
if something is shut down that means
that something else is opened up
danger oh danger but also
opportunity hmm
it's a different perspective
and then they start working to make that
happen with that vision that they're
holding in their mind you were born to
do something great with your life that
you're extraordinary listen to me that
you're enough that you're special that
you're favored that you're chosen
regardless of where you come from
regardless of what you've been carrying
with you some of you come in here today
and you know what you've even thought of
harming yourselves
maybe you're even proud of the fact you
haven't killed yourself but every day
some of us are killing ourselves with
the shame we carry from something we've
done some humiliation some fear we put
this gun to our head every day that
tells us we're not enough we're not
strong enough pretty enough smart enough
favored enough that we're doomed and we
carry these guns in our head every day
that shame us that take our confidence
from us that steal our joy it's like a
knife we you don't have to kill yourself
because you do it every day
you do it over and over and over again
and there's a better way forward you can
put those things down in your life you
could decide today that you were born to
do something great you could set aside
this weapon that you keep using against
yourself to hold you back from your joy
from your passion from your achievement
from all the goodies in life you could
decide today just intentionally to set
this weapon down whatever it is
something from your childhood a divorce
a business failure something you're just
not proud of that you've done
set it down stop using it as a weapon
against yourself and realize that
happened for you and not to you i'll
prove it to you i'm a big believer and
fake it till you make it
i don't want you seeing you know people
say well social media is so full of like
these fake lives
people have always lived fake lives i
was living a fake life way before social
media came along
in fact when i became an entrepreneur i
wanted to be somebody so bad i wanted to
be rich so bad i wanted to look i
thought if i don't look successful no
one's going to listen to me
who's going to listen to a young kid in
business about how to save your money
when i didn't have any
that was my own limiting belief what's
yours
you have this kind of convoluted and
limiting belief about why you can't do
something right now that's this your own
bs story you keep telling yourself
how about you just drop that story how
about you just decide it's a lie
even if it is true
i'm not gonna just teach you not to tap
into your pain i'm gonna teach you how
to do it
okay i'm not i i i teach people how to
change things technically but i believe
in this concept of living blissfully
dissatisfied which means there's a way
most most achievers have it backwards
they think hey if i enjoy my success i'm
going to lose all my drive
right and then other people that aren't
successful yet haven't reached what they
want or like they delay their bliss
until a destination in the future once i
get this relationship once i make that
money once i get that car once i have
that home then i'll let myself feel
bliss and so i teach you that the
concept is you can live blissfully and
still be dissatisfied your pathway to
changing how you feel about yourself of
getting to the next level is always
giving always giving always giving you
know i have this thing i kind of run my
life through
that kind of as my governor on my life
of what i'm trying to give and when i'm
trying to make a difference for people
and i just have this hallucination i am
a christian and so i believe that
someday when i die there's an accounting
i don't give you i'm actually one of
these very interesting people that i
believe in the quantum field and energy
because i know it exists and i believe
my lord and savior created him that's
you have whatever your belief is is
wonderful i don't preach i just want you
to know i know there's an energy field i
know there's a god
and um
lewis asked me on the show what are
three truths and i said the first thing
is there's a god i just want you to know
that so you believe your beliefs i
respect them i admire my people from
every belief center in the world on my
program but i just want to say to you
this is my prism i live my life through
it governs my decision-making and i make
mistakes all the time one of the cool
things about being a christian is i'm
saved by the grace of god because i know
i'm going to sin that's one of the cool
things about my particular faith but but
the point that i want to make because i
sin all the time i make mistakes all the
time i've already used profanity i think
four times in this talk so i know for
sure i've missed some mistakes but let
me tell you how i govern my life i
believe at the end of my life there's an
accounting and i'm going to sit in front
of my lord and i want to say well done
good and faithful servant but having
said that no matter what your beliefs
are
i think that i actually get to meet
somebody interesting maybe you don't
believe in anything faith-based but i
bet you believe there's a recording
going on in your life someone's paying
attention someone's going to tell the
story of your life maybe your
great-granddaughter will carry the
legacy of your life and what you've done
but someone's paying attention to what
you're doing here you've always had that
sense you've always known your life
mattered you've always known since you
were a little girl that there's
something special you're supposed to be
doing that anxiety that fear you have is
maybe you're not doing it i think we're
all an underdog
i think i think the top ceo on the
planet earth still has that doubt yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] where you're from kobe
bryant michael jordan the best on the
planet we're all underdogs
whether you're underdog because you put
yourself there to be hungry or yes a
real life underdog we're all an underdog
and so this this is about
the mind and people
discovering the mind their own mind and
one thing i know is we all have an
equation
we all have an equation like you know
i'll talk about three point you know
3.14 is pi
there's different equations to figure
out different kind of you know
mathematical problems we as human beings
are mathematical problems
i cannot give you a book
for every body in this world that's from
my book even though it's one book it's
tailored to
the individual
it's not like you do these five steps
you're good no
i'm helping you figure out your equation
because it's different my equation's
different from your equation what's
going to make you tick what's going to
make you go the distance what's going to
make you go to that spot in hell and say
i love this spot
it's okay
that's what this book does it helps you
figure out your 3.14
helps you figure out your mathematical
equation and say oh because once you
figure out the equation in any math
problem
you no longer fail man you got it
figured out i remember we had gone to
mauritius
and when we were in mauritius my team
was also with me and after i did my talk
the host said uh would you like to go
around
okay we can go around went to a couple
of places we went to the ocean we went
underneath the ocean not scuba diving we
went like 20 30 feet under the ocean
fried fish under the surface of the
water
one place we went to was called the
kasela adventure park
and then our host said would you like to
walk with lions
i said yeah
i'm extremely excited to walk with lions
the
first step
of walking with lions was
you had to sign a declaration form
another declaration declaration form
you have to write that in the lines you
have to read the clause it says if the
lines pounce on you and kill you it is
completely your response make sure you
hold the stick tight and strong in your
hands and they told us the lions were
brought up with this they came to this
park as cubs and they were brought up to
this idea that whoever holds the stick
in their hands that's a sign of respect
towards them so they won't harm you i
was taking hands
my team was looking at me luckily
so we were all holding this
sticks in our hands and we were walking
and then you must have seen the video on
youtube this is the video
that i've done on walking with the lions
and holding the tails of two lions and
walking this one holding the tails of
flying and patting those lines the guy
was thinking
i saw a very interesting thing
which in
sanskrit is called sin power
symbol means the glance of a lion
when the lion walks ahead
what the lion does
is occasionally it turns behind
line turns behind
and gets an estimate of how far it has
come from where it started
the lion turns behind
and sees what all were the hurdles what
all were the obstacles
that it crossed over to come to reach
where it is today
and it's incredible the lion looks
behind and said okay i reached here
and then the lion had its eyes
in the front
to see
where it has to go now
how much more distance to cover
what are the hurdles to come on the path
what all the line has to overcome to
reach where it has to reach
this principle is called sim
when i saw that in mauritius i said this
is such a fantastic thing to apply in
human life as well such a powerful
principle
that when we are in moving on in our
life we need to look back into the past
the past is not a place of residence
the past is a place of reference
past is not the place where we should be
staying
past is the place where we should be
visiting
we have to be a visitor in our past not
a resident of the past
and when we look into the past we can
always look at what went right for us
and celebrate those small victories or
those big victories like the lion when
it walks ahead and looks behind this is
how much distance it has covered this is
how many hurdles it has overcome these
are victories to the lion and there is
celebration
in the year 2021 when you look behind
you may have your small victories
or your big victories you may see that
something went right for you you may see
that something went incredibly good for
you some of you probably your
relationship has clicked very well and
you're probably about to get married
some of you the bonding of your
affection and love for each other in
your relationship has gone deeper for
some of you you probably made a good
profit in the last year but some of you
probably got a fantastic job in the last
year but some of you probably cleared
your academics and got
it's incredible to look back
and celebrate what went
good
learn what went right and if we learn
from what's went right and what's going
right for us we can always repeat it
from now on in the year 2022 as well we
can improvise it we can enhance it we
can we can
change the quality of it positively
and guess what
you only add value to what we are doing
and therefore like the lion it's so
important for us to turn behind
look back and reminiscing 2021
in 2022 yes
there is celebration
but along with celebration ladies and
gentlemen there must also be
deliberation
and what is the deliberation
the liberation of looking behind in
to be a better person
what could have done better to be a
better husband a better wife a better
boyfriend a better girlfriend a better
spouse a better uh employer better
businessman a better friend a better me
what could i have done better
for making my work better or by making
my study better what could i have done
better
to keep my mental fitness and my mental
wellness in place what would i have done
better
to lead a better and a happier life
yes
celebration for the victory as the lion
comes ahead overcomes so many hurdles to
come where it is
along with that celebration there is
deliberation people think that
prosperity is just money but really
there's many many other things that come
under this auspices of prosperity
you know you can be very poor in time if
you feel really rushed all the time and
always pressured you have poverty in
your time but if you feel that you have
all the time in the world and that
whatever you want to finish you'll get
done and it will it will all happen then
you're really prosperous in time
and what about success you know if you
feel that it's really way beyond your
reach
then you're never going to get it
but if you feel that you can be
successful whatever that means to you
then that's wonderful that's prosperity
do you have prosperity and wisdom do you
feel that all the wisdom in the universe
is available to you or do you think oh
i'm just me and i don't know very much
and you know i can't figure things out
if you feel that you're really connected
with the universe and you really trust
that part of you that's inside then you
can be absolutely prosperous in the
abundance of wisdom
and what about love
do you feel that you i have an abundance
of love
or are you very poor in love is there
very just a little bit of it in your
life
how about joy
do you feel you're really prosperous and
i have an abundance of joy or is that
something you just allow yourself a
little bit of now and then
and you really are very poor in joy
and then what about beauty
do you see beauty everywhere
do you allow yourself to experience an
abundance of beauty
and of course there's money then there's
money too
you know what do you let yourself have i
like to use that uh image a lot of the
ocean standing in front of the ocean
with a container in your hand you know
and you're there and you have this
container but what is it
is it a thimble with a hole in it is it
a small cracked cup
is it a mug
is it a vase but no matter how much you
have whatever your container it is and
no matter how much you're taking from
the ocean of life and even though we're
all standing there we're not robbing
each other and there's plenty for
everyone and no matter how much we take
there is no way we're going to run that
ocean drive it's absolutely impossible
and if you can see yourself standing at
the ocean of life in the same way
and remember the container that you have
is your consciousness
and you can always change your
consciousness
and it doesn't matter if you came from
poverty it doesn't matter where you came
from and it doesn't even matter what
your parents beliefs were because it's
your consciousness and what you're
choosing to think and believe about
prosperity and your ability to deserve
it
is what's going to create it for you
everybody wants to be happy and we're
all looking to be happy
and we seem to have this weird belief
that there's some destination we're
going to get to one day called happiness
but there's no destination called
happiness there's no terminal you're
ever going to arrive at in your life
called this is the happy place if you
want to be happy and why wouldn't you
want to be happy here's a way to be
happy you got to be happy right now i
see so many people who i'll be happy
when my kid can walk my kid can feed
them so i'll be happy when my kid's gone
to be happy when
and if you buy into that i'd be happy
when you're never happy because when
never comes i'd be happy when i'm
married i'm single if i could find a
great person i'd be happy and then you
know what you do you just swap all the
problems of being single to having to
compromise with somebody else because
you have this belief i'll be happy when
so if you want to be happy
here's how to be happy decide to be
happy right now don't do that i'll be
happy when i get to my holiday i'm super
stressed at the airport i'm having a
management but when i get there i'll be
happy because now you've told your mind
that happiness is somewhere you're going
to
tell your mind the truth
i am happy right now i've decided to be
happy in the moment
i'm choosing to be happy you see your
mind is set up to do what you tell it
and every time you say tomorrow i'll be
happy when it believes that happiness is
out there and you're going there but you
might never get there when you go i'm
happy right now i'm happy packing i'm
happy at the stress of the airport i'm
happy this minute i am choosing to be
happy then your mind understands the
truth happiness is now you're not going
to happiness you're not looking for
happiness and by the way
nobody else can make you happy while an
amazing partner a great career a
wonderful kid will enhance your
happiness
if you give that to someone else my
partner's going to make me happy having
a baby is going to make me happy having
a great job where i get recognized going
to make me happy getting praise is going
to make me happy you know what you're
doing
you're giving someone else a
responsibility to make you happy and if
you say to them here you go you make me
happy that will work for a while but
then you know what you're giving them
you're giving them power to make you
unhappy
i want a little baby to be happy and i
got it but now that baby is a 14 year
old teenager doesn't want to speak to me
people say oh you know you make me feel
amazing and then the other side of that
is you make me feel so angry and so
lonely and so unimportant don't give
your power to be happy to anyone else
it's up to you
and don't wait to be happy choose to be
happy right now in the moment i mean
look at little children the rain makes
them happy a puddle makes them happy
everything makes them happy because they
live in the moment happiness is an
inside job go inside you
live in the moment i promise you if you
make a decision i'm going to be happy
right now no matter what and everything
i do
you'll train your mind to be happy
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some
motivation to end your laziness check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe i'll
see you there i still grind i love to
grind if you're competing in one of my
businesses i'm gonna kick your ass
because i'm going to outgrind you
immigrants in america have absolutely
figured out one of the core secrets
which is